you I'd like to thank you organizers for
inviting me to this wonderful workshop
so many wonderful talks and stimulating
conversations and still more to come
later this week alright today I will
present some of our recent work on
actually network data integration or
network data fusion so this is just an
overview of my talk I will just briefly
introduce the problems I mean they were
introduced many in many talks I'm not
going to focus on that and then I will
present one methodology basically that
we've used over the past three years or
so to fuse various types of biological
data network and other types of data and
to do various tasks for example to
reconstruct go to find patient specific
things such a stratification drug
repurposing and biomarker discovery to
reclassify diseases based on the
evidence from multiple omics type
molecular and other data and in the end
to do multiple Network alignment and in
the past we focused mostly on single
network analysis and I'll just briefly
basically say how that contributes to to
these tasks all right so let's start
with a brief introduction and this
doesn't work why doesn't this okay okay
so we all know one of the most complex
systems that we study is the cell and in
the cell there are many different types
of networks for example there are many
types of networks between G is whether
it's coexpression or transcriptional
regulation and so forth then genes make
proteins and proteins can physically
bind to do particular task of a protein
interaction networks then we also have
the various types of networks on
diseases for example we have disease
ontology or we can leave diseases if
they are comorbid in particular patients
and so forth also on drugs we can have
various networks whether it's drug
chemical similarity or whether drugs are
to the same patient group and so forth
so basically we have all these network
data types coexpression protein
interactions various genetic
interactions metabolic networks then we
have various ontology such disease
ontology gene ontology then we can have
a drug side effects we can we have so
much data and basically there are
questions of how much information we can
take out of each of these data sources
individually and then how we fuse them
all together basically to see what they
collectively tell us and why this is
because all of these datasets give us
different views of the same system of
the living cell that complement each
other and the question is how to analyze
them collectively because only by
collective analysis we can get a full
insight all right but as we all know
it's not trivial to these with to deal
with these problems it was just a simple
things such as comparing networks it's
already a hard computational problem and
we need to rely on heuristics and
basically throughout the talk I'll point
you to basically np-hard problems for
which various types for which we design
heuristics to try to fuse these data to
learn more basically to mine information
collectively from these data types ok so
now about the methodology and first
basically I will lead you through these
four examples these these are our four
recent papers and just basically going
from the simpler model towards a more
complicated model on how we've done it
okay so let's first talk about our paper
from ECC be from a couple of years ago
how to reconstruct go from molecular
network data and Trey gave yesterday an
overview of his work on day so basically
we were inspired by his 2013 paper
basically that asked how much of can we
reconstruct go from the wiring patterns
of various types of data and unlike
trace approach we use the
semi-supervised co-clustering machine
learning methods
and that method learns from the relation
patterns both within the same type and
the types that we've used here are ppi
network genetic interaction network
coexpression network and yeast net so
this is yeast okay so one data types is
basically genes or gene products
proteins and various types of
interactions on them another data type
is go terms okay so we want to
simultaneously basically cluster these
two data types based on the evidence
from all these data so our method learns
from relation patterns both intra type
within one data type and across
different types so this is across these
I notations and predicts new gene
annotations so basically these links
between go terms and jeans but also it
in first new go term of associations
from a clustering by co-clustering
basically within the same framework and
just a result that I'll come to at the
end that we can actually crap recover
ninety-six percent of go annotations
from fusing basically just these
typologies of these data alright so how
do we do that so we want to ceylon
taneously cluster go terms and jeans and
the motivation comes from non-negative
matrix factorization which factorize is
a non-negative data matrix ok this is
homogeneous data so this is one data
type so it factorize is this non
negative data matrix into t 2 matrix
factors okay and this is an alternative
to principal component analysis inventor
vector quantization so the theoretical
foundation for nmf for clustering
homogeneous data is that it is
equivalent to a relaxed form of k-means
where this factor contains the centroids
cluster centroids and this factor
contains cluster membership and k is the
number of clusters okay and this is
basically from from this paper that this
is not our this is from 1999 okay but
this is homogeneous data this is the
same data type but we want to cluster go
terms and gene simultaneously
okay and this is why we have to use
non-negative matrix 3 factorization and
it's penalized or graph regularized to
include these penalty terms that come
from the topology from the topology of
these networks and how do we do that
okay so this matrix are 12 which is
basically go term annotations this is
relationships between genes and go terms
this is our 12 we approximated by these
three matrix factors ok so it's
penalized and I'll show you the next
slide basically it integrates topologies
or molecular networks as constrained so
that's white semi-supervised it's
non-negative so that we would have
cluster interpretation of these
estimated matrix factors and it's three
factorization because it's
simultaneously clusters columns and the
columns and rows geez and n go terms and
over here k k 1 is the number of
clusters here and k 2 is the number of
clusters here in go terms now how do we
compute it so we are approximating again
we are approximating this by these three
how do we do that so we do that by
solving a continuous optimization
problem which minimizes this so r 12
minus V is here okay this is it this is
for venience norm but under the guidance
of pairwise constraints that come here
okay now in these constraints so this is
basically these are the laplacian this
l1 or laplacian of these four matrices
and the idea here is that basically are
in these laplacian you would have a they
will have a negative value if there is
an edge okay and this will be a reward
your function basically this will you
want to minimize so this will lead your
function towards a local minimum of
course they get because this is a an
np-hard problem so we can only
approximately find this this local local
minima okay so these are this is a high
one to four these are basically the
typologies of these four networks now
these four here are the topology is
coming from graph let similarities that
Igor just mentioned
so basically while this takes into
account direct connectivity this takes
into account similarity in the wiring
patterns of faraway nodes and why is
this and I will come back to this slide
I'll just remind you that basically his
eager said absorb as eager said a more
than a decade ago introduced this graph
let's kind of the idea was that these
are Legos kind of like building blocks
of these networks and we would figure
out by the way that they are linked to
each other by these basically symmetry
groups in the more automorphism orbit so
basically the the way or these
correlations by which they come together
would tell us whether these large data
whether these legos made up make up a
pumpkin or an airplane or whatever that
is but I will not talk about graphics in
this talk I'll just try to remind you
that we have already shown long time ago
that similarity in the wiring patterns
for far away nodes means the
statistically significant similarity in
the biological function membership
protein complex in subcellular
localization tix tissue expression
involvement in disease and our
predictions of new Melanie members of
melanin production pathways with work
you know typically validated by a sorry
SI RNA screens at UC Irvine dermatology
department while I was an assistant
professor there and more recently we've
come up with a machine learning method
where we relieved basically these orbit
positions with different go terms and we
have shown that certain functional
groups tend to have preservation in the
topology even for the faraway species
and of course there is still more
improvement or on this that we haven't
published yet and the work on graph
let's we have done some work by which we
can track the network dynamics so
basically how the structure of the
network changes and everything is
recently generalized to directed network
and we just put this on archive a couple
of weeks ago but let's get back to this
topic this is why we have this term
are coming from all of these data and
this is so again and now our matrix is
roughly degree vector similarity and
then this is this is just the same stuff
there but with basically to capture that
and also we add this term not to ignore
basically we want to we don't want to
ignore what we already know from a goal
so we put that in we can put that out
but yeah in this paper we put that in
okay so now how do we minimize our
objective function well we decided to
follow multiplicative update rules
obtained from kkt optimality conditions
and many ways to do that but this is
just one way we did that so how do we do
that we basically randomly initialize
these matrices g1 and g2 then we follow
these update rule so for every model see
that they're different models you have
to derive these because we are dealing
with np-hard continuous optimization
problem and the updated rules are like
this so you know this is how you update
s12 and this is how you update g1 and g2
and you're stopping criteria basic you
stop when your functions you know when
the the difference is too small and
again this is not ours this is from the
paper from 2008 okay right so now we
know how to approximate this with these
three matrix factors and then we obtain
you knowledge out of these factors
because they were random initializations
here then we have to run it a few times
and to do drive a consensus matrix so
basically for example if we want to
figure out which grow terms are together
we go along here along this row and then
you find the maximum one we construct
this is in our eyes run see I and then
in the end we averaged over that to
derive this consensus matrix and then we
have these clusters of go terms and r12
you basically reconstruct directly so to
recover existing and predict new gene
annotations okay so now some results oh
so
the beauty here is that you can remove
any type of data and see how much
degradation to your model you get and in
this particular case we evaluate model
by residual sum of squares and explained
variance and we see here that just as a
tree mentioned yesterday that if you
remove genetic interactions and it's the
largest degradation so genetic and PPI
interactions are more relevant than
co-expression data we can argue why that
is and also we tested whether graph
let's contribute and yes if you remove
the graph that part also your model
degrades now entire data set you remove
genetic interactions all of them at the
time and you keep these and you will see
later examples how basically you know by
integrating more and more data how your
accuracy of the model improves and
that's that's why this is nice ah new
associations between a go terms so
basically we are we want to figure out
how much of this holds in the light of
the evidence from all data and basically
we find that the overlap between the go
term classes that we obtained and and
the actual goal is ninety-six percent
and then we predicted go term
associations that are currently not
present and go we predicted 132 of them
that are statistically significant and
we validated 58 of those through
literature curation now in terms of new
gene annotations I am using here go as
one of the sources you can exclude that
yes yes yes evaluation is done by
excluding although I don't remember let
me let me look it up I'll get back to
you also 96 person
it doesn't no no it just tells you
exactly exactly yeah yeah so it's an
imperfection of this method for this
particular application yeah so in terms
of a new gene annotation so basically
now we are talking about this arm until
we do a three-fold cross-validation will
remove a third of the data and this is
the area under the ROC curve this is
eighty-seven percent we evaluated so we
whether we do correct a cell assignment
of go terms to particular genes and we
find out that yes we do that and graphic
degree vectors improve results and that
we outperform what a tree talked about
yesterday and we can do that for a
cellular component biological process
and like a function and the red one is
when you include graph 'let's as well
and we actually do biological
validations of these predictions by
using Charlie boons new genetic
interaction data that is available now
online and basically you know we see you
know that the distribution of genetic
profile correlations among new annotated
gene pairs significant differs from the
distribution of the randomly sampled
ones and we use chroma Gorasni no tests
to do that all right now let's go to the
title so basically this was the first
example to because it is easiest to
describe the methodology we book because
we call okok last and only jeans and go
terms to different types now we want to
simultaneously cluster patients jeans
and drugs and to do these particular
tasks in precision medicine and this is
actually our recent paper that appeared
in PSB this year okay right so now it's
spacious specific data fusion we go to
TCGA and we got about 450 ovarian cancer
patients and as I said we have three
entities three different data types
patients jeans and drugs we have this
dramatic mutations profile so from each
individual patients we know which genes
are mutated ok on genes we go to bio
grid and Carrie have
interaction genetic interactions with
about metabolic interactions okay so
this is our r 1 2 matrix then we go to a
drug bank and we take the data about
drugs and their targets okay here and
then we have drug chemical similarity
network here and we used smiles there so
this is where the data comes from in
this particular example now this are 2 3
matrix is between these two data types
and again we are doing the same thing we
are minimizing this objective function
where r 1 2 we are approximating by this
matrix factors are 23 by these ones but
notice that we share d2 and by sharing
this matrix factor this is how we ensure
fusion of the data and then this is
again the same as before penalties
coming from the topologies so this is
how that works okay and basically for
drug repurposing we want to reconstruct
some of the new of these are two three
this comes directly from you know our 23
here patient stratification comes from
this factor so this is clustering of
patients based on evidence of all of
these data and driver gene prediction
this is the biomarker we wanted to
figure out whether we can do something
with it so a driver gene prediction
comes with this from this g2 and this is
those consensus matrices that i told you
about because of these randomness in
these experiments some results overview
of the results i don't have much time
less than five minutes left so in terms
of patient stratification this method
gives us three patient group three
groups of patients with statistically
significantly different survival curves
kaplan-meier survival curves and
basically be something that you free
species I for you ah aha there is so
basically you know when there's those
key parameters then you play with them
right and then that's the one that gives
the best clustering mmm again another
thing of the methodology yes ok so
that's inter
of patient stratification in terms of
predicting driver genes basically it
comes from here and we see that the kind
of the functions that are involved in
cell proliferation progression apoptosis
and so forth now we predicted 199 new
driver genes but forty percent of them
we validated in databases that we didn't
use in this particular fusion experiment
right so this is where the validations
come from and this is what I told you
this is how I will show you how
basically your accuracy improves as you
add more data for drug repurposing
basically reconstruct think this matrix
this is when you only take drug target
interactions to infer new drug target
interactions and this the there is a red
is the area under the ROC curve and this
is arian the precision recall curve and
basically as you add more data you see
that basically with the addition of all
data you are I mean it's the best
performance of the model and we
predicted many new drug target
interactions and then thirty-seven
percent of them we confirmed in
basically the databases that we did not
use here okay this is a work in
preparation we work with the professor
stabbings lab at Imperial this is a
small set of cancer patients at 45
patients and this is just an
illustration how all cancers are
different so we have this is hard to
read I'm sorry about that so this is our
45 patients and this is basically how
many genes are mutated in them and we
see that most patients a very small
number of genes mutated at five to ten
this is G's there is one around 180 g is
mutated in these 45 patients and we see
that a particular gene these are
particular genes you know it would
prefer G would be mutated in very small
number of patients unless it's tp53
which is mutated in less than a half of
page so very very versatile
is so we have these patients we have
drugs we have jeans again you have
different networks here you have
different relations between different
data types and you want to use them all
to predict which drugs although the
approved drugs should be given to which
particular patients based on all of this
based on their mutations and evidence of
all data and again I would like to
stress that here basically you're
decomposing all of these but you're
sharing these matrix factors and this is
why this works so this g one over there
g 3 over there and g2 right there ok and
i don't have much time but i just like
to say that we did also disease reckless
a reclassification basically the disease
ontology the way doctors learn it now is
about a hundred years old and based only
on the symptoms and the most affected
organs and the question is how much of
that classification still holds in the
light of the codes in the light of a new
molecular level data they did not exist
a hundred years ago and we've all seen
these kind of projection methods and we
know there are limitations and we
actually did again similar type of
fusion but again I need to stress that
each of these I mean you have two
different multiplicative update rules or
you have to design how to decide how to
converge and these are not non trivial
problems and their computer densities as
well so over here the model is the most
complicated in the sense that you now
have four different types of objects
your genes and different types of
interactions on them you have drugs and
different types of drug interactions on
let me have gene ontology and disease
ontology and you are fusing it all as
before you get all of these data from
public databases but now basically we
use these block matrices we put the
stuff in to block matrices and then we
do the same sort of thing this this sort
of a optimization again multiplicative
update rules consensus matrix and so
forth and I'm sorry I'm almost running
out of time but some results that for
example 14 we find 14 disease disease
associations that are currently not
present in disease ontology for which we
find evidence of their relationship
through comorbidity
data and literature curation again
genetic interactions for human even
though they're very small there were the
most important predictor because again
we tested how well the fusion works we
then without certain data but a mission
of so basically every type of data
contributes to the quality of the model
and interestingly eighty percent of
disease ontology we can recover from
fusing all of these types of data so
there is still a room for improvement
and lastly I'll just gloss over this in
a couple of slides to do multiple
Network alignment we know that it's much
harder than doing pairwise network
alignment and it has to be heuristic so
in our recent bioinformatics paper from
a few months ago we use the similar
methodology to align the five largest
PPI networks that we have so far human
drosophila Mouse C elegans and yeast so
again use block representation all of
this is just illustrate this is just
illustration of from human to everybody
else r 12 r 13 or 14 i want for but
everything else is there is our 25 and
and so forth right and this is again to
illustrate basically are sharing this g
1 over all of these and this is how you
fuse all of these data now between so
here an interesting thing is that these
are 12 and so forth are 23 and so forth
they come from sequence similarities so
you put in sequence similarities but
then you integrate them by imposing
penalties from the topology of these
data but now even once you do your model
and you reconstruct these basically so
now based on the alignment basically
based on the sequence similarity amongst
all these five networks and topological
fusion topological similarity of all
these ppi networks you come up with this
course these are 12 is reconstructed RI
JS but then you still have to address a
maximum weight cut part I'd matching
problem this is five part I'd here which
is np-hard k part and matching problem
is np-hard already for cage most of
three or more
so we have a small heuristic here
basically how you solve that and it
deals with merging data sets in some
specific order that gives you the best
the best performance and in terms of
results only quick remarks that from
sequence alignment so this is basically
top scoring paper appears of annotated
proteins in millions and this is
percentage of functionally consistent
pairs from sequence you see the dashed
lines are from sequence and the solid
lines are from basically this data
fusion approach for biological processes
read and molecular function is blue and
when you compare to other methods
basically you want to find these
clusters that are basically in the same
cluster you want to have genes from all
species right at a line based on to this
collective evidence so the more species
you have the genes for more species in
the cluster the better so this is two
species in a cluster 3 4 5 so blue is
good and this is fuse this is our
multiple network alignment and you see
that compared to other methods we have
fewer clusters but they are basically
they contain nodes from all five species
then over here is the number of proteins
in those classes even though we have
fewer clusters we have just as many
proteins as for example beams and other
methods so coverage is of use is really
nice and also infused we have the most
biological process consistent clusters
and molecular function consists of
classes this is fuse this is used this
is competitors and basically this is
from all so you have clusters of these
genes from all species that are
biologically consistent based on the
evidence from sequence anthropology's
all these methods okay so just to
summarize we have seen one methodology
others are coming how to deal with a
diffusion like many of the speakers have
already addressed we've seen just for
examples of the same methodology that is
fairly versatile
I think it can be very useful and there
is still more to come we still have so
much more data to come and we will need
new tools and this is very nice exciting
area to being just to thank the funding
agencies my group members I'm current
and past and to announce that I've just
moved two weeks ago to university
college london and i started my full
professorship there so i'm starting a
new group and looking for new postdocs
and PhD students so if you have somebody
had to send me please please do so thank
you very much for attention all these
populations you have different data time
yes very surprising that there are no
coefficient so you yes that's very nice
you can do that yes you can here there
is a little coefficient I didn't focus
on that gamma and this gamma basically
is how much you get from sequence and
how much weight you want to give to
topology and it turns out that 0.7 gave
the best result 0.7 contribution of the
topology so this is the topology
obviously here so you can do this
previous ones known ha this is kind of a
future research thing one of the
students is working on that yes but we
didn't
and
ah you mean this block matrix yeah JJ is
your this is your you're minimizing this
sort of thing yeah oh and everything is
inside of these these love
in each one of these it boils down that
you are approximating this are 12 with
with you know the proper thing there jay
jay is just not you mean g or j g yes g
are always so basically or you mean in
this particular example interpretation
of ji ji ji ji ji ji right this one
right here okay right so this is well
let me let me worry I don't know yeah
it's basically from human this is from
human to all of these other guys right
so these are sequence similarities and
then we want to reconstruct these based
on this and the topologies so G 1 times
d2 d3 and so forth so yeah this is the
clusters yeah the clusters okay yes yes
you want these sorts of things I think
it might be easier if you look at it on
other examples so let live meal yeah but
there is a real interpretation of that
always like for example in this
particular one this is patient groups it
depends what you are clustering
sometimes its patients other times is
going to be driver G's or like jeans
clusters of jeans right and you'll be
looking for the ones that it so it's all
it just depends on what data here it's
easier because a different type so it's
easier over there that they're all genes
but from different species